hello everyone and uh welcome to this
session
i will briefly introduce some of the
objectives of this training and then i
will pass it on to dr raghav to speak
about
how this will be done and what are some
examples of things that you could do
with this so the data science program
is designed to introduce statistical
analysis and machine learning
provide you with an understanding of how
data is generated so how you can for
example think about your experiments if
you're going to be using data science to
analyze your own data
or how to evaluate other people's data
and spot trends that might represent
technical versus biological variation
we'll talk about the significance of
data mining and finding patterns that
can lead to interpretation so you can
actually think about patterns that ui
identify complex patterns that are not
simply let's say differentiation between
means of groups but how to find these
complex patterns and incorporate
association
and then finally how to study complex
biological systems using big data and so
when i speak about complex biological
systems
any system in our body for example
whether it is uh you know our nervous
system or
you know immune system
these systems are complex because they
represent many different cell types they
represent many different associations
and connections and they are also
dynamic so there's a time course
component in them as well and so when we
look at data how can we apply data
science and machine learning and
statistical analysis to be able to
actually understand these biological
systems that is going to be the major
objective of this program so how are we
going to do this first of all this is
going to help you understand various
types of omics data
and understand how data analysis that
you see in publications for example
are actually done and and how they are
representative of both the biology and
the data side of things uh you'll talk
about
uh you'll learn about the significance
of exploratory analysis and actually how
to prepare your data
for let's say classification how to
prepare your data for biological
interpretation
you'll be able to find patterns that are
biologically explainable and importantly
you'll learn how to communicate your
findings to your peers so you will be
able to connect the dots between
data preparation data processing data
analysis and biological significance
and i think the major objective here for
most
of the participants that are joining
today is to really understand well you
know how am i going to get to this
where i am at right so maybe you are
thinking okay these are some nice
objectives but how do i actually know
that i am at the right level that i have
their prerequisites that i'm ready for
something like this well that's exactly
the goal of omics logic our goal is to
actually
be able to show you how anyone whether
you're a high school student an
undergraduate student a postgraduate
student maybe a faculty
and still you can benefit from this
program so i'm going to take a few
slides to speak about some of the
important aspects of data science in
general and then speak about
specifically how you can use the
specific illustrations case studies and
project examples that we will use in the
full program to be able to understand
and achieve something with this kind of
training so um first of all uh today
i'll talk about uh some of the specifics
for biologists right we'll talk about
data science but specifically we're
talking about data science for
biological data and i'll talk about some
of the challenges and some of the
opportunities for someone who is coming
from a biological background and i'll
try to make sure that the logic for why
you would need to study these things why
you would need to use these tools how do
you actually go from a to b and what
would be the outcome and so the goal
of this whole training actually is going
to be to be able to
find and understand
what data represents
how to prepare the data for analysis
learn code syntax and be able to
identify
what is the question
and how to answer it and i think to
understand why data science it's
important to understand what data
science actually is
and that will help us kind of get back
to that same point in a few slides and
think about whether this is achievable
so data science as you know is the
intersection between data
statistics and some specialization
domain and so when we talk about
statistics typically we're referring to
the balance between signal and noise in
our data sometimes we can for example
do some experiment and maybe every once
in a while we see some interesting
pattern maybe the gene that we are
interested in
sometimes is expressed sometimes is not
expressed
and what we would like to know is
whether
we can generalize our understanding
whether what we see in our experiment
could then be applied to biology in
general and so that's where statistics
can help us it can help us understand
how
random patterns are different from
patterns that are reproducible recurring
and significant and so that is the
difference between signal and noise and
to be able to spot signal and noise we
either need a lot of samples or we need
to know some advanced methods that can
extract those specific signals
and help us identify the ones that are
reliable and the ones that are not then
on the data
we have in general just the problem of
noisy data and structured and
unstructured data the data is just not
ready for the type of analysis that we
would like to do
and this is especially true for
complex data analysis so when we we
think about machine learning we
typically think about
data that has classes that has many
groups those groups are well defined we
don't have any failed processes because
our data misses some
numbers or something like this
and so that is really the problem with
data and then of course it's not
important just to have some data
it's important to understand that data
and so when we speak about
specialization we can think about our
understanding of that domain
in terms of the terminology in terms of
the expected variability and in terms of
anticipated artifacts that we can try to
identify prevent and avoid
and so that really brings us to a very
similar chart that represents here
bioinformatics so today bioinformatics
is less focused on maybe some niche
applications of algorithms and computer
science and in general is becoming
broader because data science apply to
any kind of biological challenge or
problem or question ends up
using that specialization domain of
biology and so what are some things that
we need to know in biology that are
important for us to be able to work with
data well one of the things that we need
to understand is how this data
represents biological
for example phenomena how this
experiment produces data that i know
operates with certain elements and i
understand those elements so that
specialization domain is really
something that we need to think about as
we
approach this topic of data science in
bioinformatics
as you can see bioinformatics and data
science are very similar the difference
between them is that bioinformatics is
very
focused on biological problems and data
science is focused on general
application of these tools
and somewhere in the middle
of both of these sits the term machine
learning right so we actually want to
incorporate machine learning because
machine learning when it is properly
applied to the right kind of question to
the right kind of data and is
interpretable
makes it useful for biological and
biomedical discovery and so today we'll
briefly talk about some of these tools
like supervise and unsupervised learning
and speak about some of the differences
between deep learning and machine
learning as well but let's first turn to
data so as you know
biomedical research is a an engine that
keeps on churning out new data sets all
the time so you can see this graph on
the left you can see that over the 27
years that ncbi has been around there
has been an exponential growth in
the availability of data that actually
is available for all of us
one of the examples is this current
pandemic that we can see has produced
such a tremendous amount of data that
today when you speak about mutations
variance
sequencing everyone knows these terms
and not just people who specialize in
that domain and that just shows you not
only an example of how data is generated
but also the trajectory how this data
will continue to be generated also in
the future now the problem is that most
of this data that is being studied is
actually unstructured and so if we think
about this process of data being
generated
and then how this data needs to be
organized so that we can start mining it
for patterns
we then understand that the process from
raw data to actual insights and
therefore action
leads through a pipeline of
data scientists right and so as we
become more informed with data science
more skilled in data science methods we
now can participate in translating this
raw data
into action and to do that we need to
understand the different types of data
and we need to be able to identify
and learn how to use
data that is already structured
so what is in plain terms the difference
between structured and unstructured data
well if i take a survey
i can ask you uh what is your level of
education
and many of you will have different
answers somebody will say
i'm a graduate student someone will say
i am learning biology at university xyz
somebody will say i'm a professor
so how do i analyze such a diverse set
of answers
what i ultimately want to do is
categorize everything that i have into
just a few small groups and compare them
between each other similar to what i see
here on the right
and that is really the difference so how
do i go from this unstructured stream of
information being shared in different
formats to ultimately something that is
organized and easily comparable
now this is a simple example but let's
think about biology well in biology a
lot of times we're dealing with high
throughput automated technologies these
are technologies that can produce
images they can produce sequencing data
like genomics
epigenomic peaks that i can study for a
different kind of variation produced by
epigenetic processes or i can analyze
gene expression tables
all of these different types of data
come in an
unstructured format and the first goal
that i have is to actually organize them
into a table into a matrix because a
matrix is something that now i can apply
different types of data
methods data analysis methods too
so
all of these types of data imaging
clinical streaming data omix data
chemical data phenotypic data what first
we will need to do is to organize them
as
structured data and once we have a lot
of such data
now we can connect the dots between
patterns and their biological
interpretation and so a major portion of
what we will do on this program is link
all of these steps together so that we
have a coherent plan we know how to
approach these kinds of problems we know
what each data type represents and we
know how to get from raw
to structure to interpretable inputs
so
if you could please monitor
the participants in terms of
sound that would be great
so ultimately our goal is in the end to
be able to ask questions
identify data sets and produce answers
that are reliable and can be used for
actionable activities so we'll talk
about examples in basic research
translational research and biotechnology
and pharmaceutical industry as well as
biomedical applications such as clinical
trials and
precision medicine
ultimately the goal or what you should
expect to have after you complete this
program
is number one
how to find data and understand what it
represents so we'll actually use a few
case studies examples that we will
provide for you
but we will also guide you on how to
find similar data sets on public
repositories such as ncbi
and others
we'll also understand how to prepare
data for analysis so we'll talk about
how this raw data could be downloaded or
what are some effective tools for you to
be able to use on the cloud so you don't
have to deal with huge amounts of data
that this represents and be able to
process them and prepare them for
analysis
you will also learn code syntax so you
understand not only how to read code but
which part of the code represents what
type of method and how to modify that
code so that you can apply it to a new
data set that you're interested in
as well as statistics and machine
learning fundamentals so that means that
you can understand the principles why
are we looking at p values at r squared
at
area under curve
what do these things actually mean
then you will be able to look at a data
problem and understand what is needed to
solve that problem so framing a problem
correctly is very important because
you'll be able to start asking questions
that could actually be answered with a
process
and then you will be able to navigate
biological or biomedical references to
be able to also interpret and validate
results of the analysis because a lot of
kind of questions to these machine
learning methods is well what does this
method really do how do i interpret this
and how do i know that it's a valid
interpretation
and finally we'll also give you an
opportunity to be able to communicate
and contribute to data science and
machine learning code of others
or communicate your project results to
others as well so really omixlogic
provides you with a complete roadmap to
data science specifically in application
to biomedical research data and we hope
that this kind of training can simplify
the path
in this complex field of biomedical
research from where you are today to
where you ultimately want to be which is
whether you want to advance your career
develop your first research project or
use this kind of methodology in your
current research
with that i would be glad to briefly
mention that all of this content is
supported by an asynchronous library of
materials that you can
refer to during the training and this
material is enriched by case studies in
various domains designed to introduce
the specific terminology specific data
sets examples and case studies that you
can start with so that you can develop
your own independent project
with this kind of data in mind